welcome welcome welcome to another
episode of fantasy and news I'm your
disheveled goblin host Daniel Green and
we have an awesome mix of fantasy news
to jump in here today including Wheel of
Time
hardcore fantasy news a good amount of
video game news we're gonna get through
pretty quickly and of course at the end
some more general fantasy news including
some things around a certain streaming
service I'd like to cover so not any
further ado let's go ahead and dive
right on into it with a mega shout out
to fellow fantasy nerd and youtuber
quinn AKA ideas of Ice and Fire for his
upcoming graphic novel release Todd yeah
it looks outstanding described as a
fantasy horror graphic novel I'm 100%
down I already went ahead and backed the
campaign which I'll have linked in the
description down below we've talked
about this before how Quinn has this
coming down the road but now it's
officially launching and you can get one
two or three editions hardback or
paperback signed or not very cool it's
just like seeing someone achieve a dream
I hope to achieve one day respect I
cannot wait to get my copy and Quinn
when I do the judgment of your lifetime
cuz you know I have to do my job and
read and review it but you know I'll be
I'll be honest it's my job but I'm sure
it's gonna be great there's a lot of
stigma around youtubers releasing books
where people are like oh it's like a low
effort but this looks high effort and it
looks quite impressive so I'm 100% here
for it and the next piece of news though
for my Wheel of Time fans out there we
are having a hard back metallic 30th
anniversary release oh my lord it's been
30 years ha edition for the eye of the
world to be released this October it's
kind of taking that original cover and
just stripping away some of the more
distracting elements and keeping more
rain and land at the forefront it looks
quite good I'm going to order a copy and
go ahead and review it for you I'm gonna
have an affiliate link right down there
if you'd like to go ahead and purchase
yourself full disclosure I do get a
kickback from that so if you don't want
to use that link go right ahead and
don't if you hate me I guess but slidin
from Wheel of Time into a Song of Ice
and Fire news we had George our Martin
put on his Twitter that he has an
extended awesome super cool narrated bit
from a feast for crows if you would like
to see the extended fate of Riverrun you
can go ahead and check out that
soundcloud link and you will get this
little twelve minute recording from Roy
to Troy's interesting combo there and
for all the people who are commenting
I'm George R Martin's post sing lose the
book you're annoying and obnoxious leave
the man alone ah he's giving you free
content and you're just badgering him
whatever moving on Christopher Paolini
had a very interesting announcement he
announced on Twitter because almost all
fantasy news is released on Twitter now
that the narrator for his upcoming
release to sleep in a sea of stars will
be Jennifer Hale that's right Commander
Shepard is coming on through and going
to narrate to sleep in a sea of stars
from Christopher Paolini very cool I
wasn't aware she was doing audio book
narration that's super dope I want to
pull her in for mine when I get my book
I have that kind of star power I'm
totally I can do that but speaking of
interesting news from authors we also
had an announcement for Rebecca Quang
author of the poppy war who for
up-and-coming authors probably has some
pretty inspirational news here to keep
you going
she has been hired on to contribute to
the 40 stories celebrating 40 years
release coming down from Star Wars
that's right this rising star in fantasy
is going to be contributing to the
largest most successful SFF franchise
currently in existence hot damn that's
cool to hear and I love seeing it it
makes me have a little bit of respect
for Star Wars for keeping their ear to
the ground within fantasy and picking an
author who definitely has credibility to
do so and it also for other authors I
imagine just gives you some hope that
one day you could do a dream like this
so I'll be picking up this 40 story
celebrating for years book I'm sure I
have to buy so many books oh oh well
they're tax write-off of all so that's
that's good okay so now let's go ahead
and talk in depth about a story here
that I want to touch on because we had a
strange announcement from The Witcher
showrunner who said that season 2 will
not be as confusing as some people found
season 1 and I have a couple things to
say about this to everyone who commented
on my before you watched The Witcher TV
show video like no one needs this we all
get it yeah if you've read the book it
makes sense that video wasn't for you
that video is from people who hadn't
read the
books so get off and - it's just strange
to hear a showrunner come out and be
like I get it was confusing for you
would be less confusing this time around
but it does make sense within the
Witcher timeline obviously season 1
covered a lot of the short stories and
so season 2 it appears from where it is
narrative Lee will instead pick up with
a more straightforward storyline which
if you're aware of how the books go that
is pretty much how it is so yes I like
that it fits and I'm looking forward to
it I have a deep-seated suspicion in my
little belly right here or on my face I
guess that season 2 of Witcher will be
better than season one because I think
Netflix kind of took the criticism that
I a lot of people myself included had
for season one that it felt a bit rushed
and narrative Lee could have been
tightened up a bit so I think they'll
take more time here as well as the co
vid delays I'm sure if allowed the more
VFX time as a lot of shows have been
talking about they've been having so
we're probably gonna have like a wave of
some of the best the effects we've seen
in TV because all these shows about more
time to polish certain shots that's good
I guess so I think season 1 I still
maintain I think like a six point five
seven out of ten I'm hoping season two
could go into that 7.5 possibly even
eight if they really listen and do their
homework and are a little more true to
the source material maybe don't make it
feel as cheap for certain shots looking
at you dragon that was awful anyway
that's just my thoughts there let me
what you think this will be a this will
be a hotly contested point of debate I
imagine because certain people hated
that show and others loved it some
people were saying it's better than Game
of Thrones green Daniel here for a quick
cut in this is not exactly a sponsorship
but I have been sent a ton of
interesting stuff from people grin a D&D
expansion company that has rather
outstanding stuff this is really
incredible they have really badass Maps
with this guy right here tons of these
tokens giant tank things top the place
it's all outstanding looking and if
you're the kind of person who enjoys
having some outside the box
unorthodox interesting well-made D&D
add-ons these guys
definitely make some quality content you
can take it and run with their
established campaigns and things along
those lines or you can just kind of do
what I do which is you use it for a
ground base to then do your own stuff
with but yes go ahead and check them out
I'll leave a link in the description if
you're looking for some interesting D&D
stuff so we're gonna go ahead and get
through some video game news here and
I'm gonna kind of just slice through
these because there was just so much EA
dropped the trailer for their upcoming
Star Wars game squadron some of those
you like myself who like dog fighting
games and planes and some pupae shoot
bangs this is gonna be right up your
alley
and it's EA you decided you want to
support them for not I'm probably not I
just I just don't like them I just don't
like them sam-i-am but we also had a
sneak peak drop for the upcoming Miles
Morales spider-man game which boy I wish
I could play but it's a ps5 exclusive
and so I can't you're gonna notice a
trend of that because this is all news
that came with the PS 5 announcement and
I'm hurting on the inside Resident Evil
Village which seems to be pretty typical
for Resident Evil game it's pretty dark
looking that's got some spooky stuff
very reliant on jump scares had a
trailer drop as well sure the Resident
Evil fans are excited and zombies that's
not overdone mutants not overdone at all
it's all still fresh
yeah I don't know why I mean so hearts I
have no problem with Resident Evil
there's also apparently going to be a
remake of Demon Souls meet but one that
actually grabbed my eye more than the
rest I just talked about here was a hard
sci-fi it appears to be release coming
down the road pragmatic this was a kind
of just cinematic it wasn't actually a
trailer with any gameplay so but it
looked different there's a vibe here of
a much more traditional hard sci-fi
narrative which of course put its little
hooks in me and makes me more curious I
still definitely see some more including
actual gameplay before I'll say like
this looks like I'm for sure bye because
I never recommend buying a game before
you actually see gameplay or even wait
for the first round of reviews but that
piqued my interest we also got a
boulders gate three community update
where they said they're going to have an
early access version available for fans
hands August maybe they very clearly
wanted to be a maybe because
they've had delays though they have said
even with Kovac going on they have
people back in the studio working on the
game getting it ready for its release
later this year fantastic
I'm not really in the boulders gate but
I have a lot of you are so yeah
righteous but topping all of this game
news we had a new horizon game trailer
drop that's right rise and zero Don is
getting its sequel horizon forbidden
West all it looks so good
I haven't even be able to play the first
game beyond like 10 minutes at a
friend's house but I've watched a lot of
gameplay from it and if there's any game
that's gonna sell me on getting a PS 5
it's this I'm not because I don't game
that much anymore and it's not worth it
but there is a voice in my head that's
like look how pretty these crabs are you
want them buying the game look at this
fish the water it's gorgeous it's sci-fi
primitive it looks outstanding I'm not
buying a PS 5 I will wait for it to be
released on the PC I will not buy a psi
really won't I won't
that's not happening it's not happening
we also had a little bit of news and I'm
sure is gonna cause some discussion but
Sigourney Weaver has confirmed she will
not be returning to the Alien franchise
and I am gonna stay a strong opinion
here good Ridley Scott seems to be
reducing the Alien franchise from its
once iconic horror sci-fi status to more
and more just horse schlock I don't hate
the new Alien movies as much as a lot of
people do but this franchise has just
been taken through the wringer put in
different directors hands different
writers hands and it seems that no one
has a cohesive vision and even now that
it's back in Ridley Scott's hands I
haven't been loving where it's going the
first two movies are classics one of the
best horror movies and one of the best
horror action movies they are total
top-tier but since then it's just been
this wave of destruction
Prometheus showed some potential but
there was a lot of issues there and then
from that we've just had covenant which
that was just a slasher movie disguised
as alien with some BS philosophy thrown
on top I did not like it and it was
disappointing sigourney weaver's actual
quote was I don't know said Weaver
Ridley has gone in a different direction
maybe Ripley has done her bit she
deserves a rest which to me very much so
just sounds like Sigourney Weaver being
like nah that's not something I want to
be involved in and I would agree with
her you're a queen and you should not be
forced to be in this franchise anymore I
love you Sigourney Weaver and I like you
even more hearing you kind of being like
nah I'm good and in a this kind of feels
like a gimmick piece of news
HBO Mack's in DC comics are teaming up
to have a free line of comics available
for readers to delve on into that
apparently will be filled with Easter
eggs for content available on HBO max
this comic book series line will be
titled to the max and I have a lot of
feeling in me that this is not going to
be something worth checking out even
though it's free it just seems like a
marketing promotional tool between DC
and HBO max which have of course a
massive catalog overlap now with HP imax
hosting so much of the DC EU and their
animated movies and all that so I'm
including this just to go and kind of
put a note of this is the future of
fantasy marketing we're likely to be
seeing a lot of for a good while now in
the final bit of fantasy news I want to
cover here today it's by no means
hardcore fantasy news but we a lot of us
get our fantasy shows through streaming
services and this is like a big piece of
streaming service news it appears that
HBO is officially shelving HBO GO which
is now officially a no-go HBO now will
be rebounded as just HBO and HBO Maxx
will remain as is so they're trying to
simplify because of the confusion around
the rebranding so just to get this
absolutely clear to the viewers HBO GO
is a no-go and is now no longer going to
be a place you can go to watch HBO
content HBO now is going to be just HBO
so now you're gonna refer to as HBO now
it's just HBO and HBO Maxx is going to
remain HBO Maxx the place where you can
get the max amount of content does that
make sense to you I think it does this
has been your latest episode of fantasy
news
I can subscribe if you have not already
puts your favorite story of the day in
the comments down below I actually do we
even care about those because it lets me
know what I should cover more in the
future and have a good piece
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]